So, the C739T allele is referred to as a loss of function allele for the OPN1LW
gene. Because the red cone cells lose the
ability to detect long wavelengths, or red light. As
a result, the combination of colors an individual
can see is altered. Take this rainbow of colors
for example, if you have normal color vision,
then you should be able to distinguish these six
individual panels from each other as red,
orange, yellow, green, blue, and purple or violet.
But in the case of this C739T allele of the OPN1LW gene, an individual has
something called protanopia. And this is what
they would see, instead of the six colored
rainbow here. Protanopia is a severe type of
color division deficiency, caused by the complete absence
of the red photoreceptors. Like OPN1LW. Pure
reds can not be seen, they instead appear
sort of dark and black. Purple colors
can't really be distinguished from blues and more
orange tinted reds kind of appear as very
dim yellows. And pretty much all orange, yellow,
green shades, of too long a wave
length to stimulate the other colors, like blue,
appear just as a yellow color. So based on the
comparison we just did, I want you to tell me which
of the following you would expect a person with protanopia, or
red/green color blindness, to have trouble with. But I want you
to do this based on the colors alone that you
see in the examples. Just the colors. I want you to
look at each answer individually. And then check any and all
that you think apply. And remember, if you have trouble distinguishing
the colors that you see here. You might want to
visit your doctor and get checked out for color blindness.